now yair Rodriguez we does have in his
Arsenal is he can pull something off
whether it's an unexpected kick or vocal
Nazi like you did against uh Mike Jeff
and kept going the body got caught
coming up that could happen and yeah
Rodriguez just has The Knockout power to
get it done uh with one of those Hail
Marys and he's always dangerous so he
does have that going for him but I think
nine times out of ten vocalosi beats the
out yeah Rodriguez hate to tell you
guys but yeah it does have that you know
that Arsenal where the kicks is weird
transition submissions he has that weird
X Factor that you can't really train for
so that could catch a guy like
volkanovsky the odds are very low and
that would be the only way he wins he
can't go toe-to-toe with vocal knots for
five rounds to beat him if it goes
decision it's a landslide win for
volcanovski I think the first round or
two there's been a lot of feeling out
with kicks button obviously covers
ground better than anybody in the UFC so
the Height's not a big deal so I think
it's been a long night in the office
right for Yaya Rodriguez super long
night